au commencement il y avait une envie
celle d'un industriel du début du 20e
siècle ivan morozov ne voyait pas
pourquoi il aurait fallu laisser aux
aristocrates de saint pétersbourg le
monopole de la francophilie et de la
passion pour l'art pictural le port sur
la baltique alors la réputation d'être
plus ouvert sur l'europe mais ivan
morozov est un moscovite convaincu il
vient d'un milieu de la grande
bourgeoisie pas de l'aristocratie c'est
la nouvelle génération en des
collectionneurs qui était en train de
naître dans la russie de l'époque donc
c'est là c'est la collection pas
d'apparat c'est pas la collection
impériale qui était créé cette époque
depuis catherine la grande anse saint
pétersbourg donc c'est vraiment son goût
personnel c'est son univers personnel
et surtout oh il ne pensait pas à
l'opinion de public il pensait vraiment
à ce monde a sa vie intellectuelle et il
crée son univers à lui par cette
collection
cette collection c'est son frère
mireille qu'il avait commencé à sa mort
en 1903 il va mérites de ses toiles et
poursuit la quête de son aîné selon la
commissaire de l'exposition
morozov aurait tenté d'édifier un musée
de la peinture française à moscou avec
l'aide d'autres grands amateurs d'art et
même si ces sommes ne sont pas parvenus
à bâtir le musée de leurs rêves leurs
passions témoigne de la proximité
culturelle existant à l'époque entre ces
deux pays c'est la possibilité de
montrer au public international qu en
russie d'avant on a eu des grands
connaisseurs grand collectionneur qu'on
suivait tout ce que s'est passé en
europe et surtout à paris que nos deux
cultures était vraiment très liés
c'était l'époque quand la russie par les
français
morozov parlait parfaitement bien
français il était à bien introduit dans
la société française et on montre c'est
aussi l'exposition qui montre que
l'europe restait uni qu'il n'y a pas
deux mondes différents l'occident
enrichit donc réuni 200 pièces de la
collection morozov seront exposées à
paris jusqu'au 22 février 2022 une
occasion unique de voir ces oeuvres
d'art avant qu'elle ne reprenne
définitivement leur place dans leurs
musées respectifs